this is a podcast normally done with all
of us in the same room but as you can
imagine because of the corona virus
pandemic we've all isolated ourselves
we're all in our homes and we're doing
this remotely I'm able to see people
courtesy of zoom which seems to be how
everybody's doing everything these days
and you know what it's fun I prefer
being in the same room with my squad
you know why does it make you laugh
Taylor Swift has a squad and you're my
you're my squad you're my you're my girl
squad quad is so much cooler than us
though she's got super models and I
don't know I guess what I don't think
her squad is cooler than our squad you
know I don't think Gigi Hadid is
inherently is that that's that the right
person to I get one right yes you did
okay you did I'm proud of you yes good
yes she hangs out with Gigi Hadid and
Peter Falk and in that one Tyrone Powell
and she's you know and and and the
Salvador Dali she's got her cool people
and the guy who did all the sound
effects on the police squad movies
police academy not police squad yeah
Michael Winslow so she's got her cool
squad but I think my squad is just as
cool you know if Selena Gomez came up to
you and said I'll join your squad but
you have to get rid of you know Matt
would you do it yes oh wow you didn't
even hesitate bet yeah I mean it's
Selena Gomez and Matt I you know first
of all Matt Gourley our producer does a
terrific job but I think Selena Gomez
could do that job I think that's
something she could learn don't you yeah
but I could do her job are you kidding
you could be that you could be like the
face of Noxzema beauty cleanser you
could wear a certain kind of legging and
immediately get you know it the sales go
through the roof of that legging I'm
doing it now right I can see you
actually I just saw you lift your leg
that was impressive
maybe you're right so yeah I got
macaroni here and and son I'm obsessed
you and I don't need to do I even need
to introduce sona anymore I mean but I
think it's the polite thing yeah okay so
all right well Sona Sona
I consider you guys my squad like Taylor
Swift has her squad
yeah and dual eepa probably has her
squad on my kids can't believe I even
know who do Aleppo is I'm shocked you
just said her name I'm absolutely
shocked yeah I thought it was a country
and yeah I said I thought oh I would
love to get a stamp from do Aleppo or
maybe I'll do a travel show to do a Lipa
or what's the main export by do Aleppo
and then they told me no no you're
you're an idiot I know everything there
is about the country of do Aleppo it
doesn't exist and nothing about the
absolutely famous and super talented
singer named do Aleppo but I wish what
if I started to have a squad that was
wouldn't that puzzle everybody if my
squad had the Hadid sisters in it Karlie
Kloss yeah exactly and I was constantly
doing stuff with my girl squad and it
just baffled people they're like I don't
understand one of these things does not
go with the other like all of them
together you know in some cool location
and I'm in the picture too wearing an
ill-fitting jacket and I don't know I'm
just obsessed with getting a squad I
want a cool squad will be your squad
yeah
[Music]